welcome back to the Rich Eisen show man
loved his work in the shield where he
played detective Shane Vendrell and then
Boyd Crowder and justified just
fantastic now Billy a baby Billy Freeman
in the righteous gemstones on HBO but he
is the Unicorn on that the show called
the unicorn on CBS that airs tonight and
every Thursday at 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time
on CBS good to see you Walton come on
man how are you I'm great man I'm so
good thank you very much for the
invitation
absolutely so now let's get right into
it so you're from you're born in Alabama
but then move to Georgia yeah yeah yeah
I mean if as if we're in charge of that
year-old
I know and yeah you know born in a like
a like a one-bedroom trailer you know
with my mom and my dad and and I think I
think my mom's sisters lived with them
for a little while and then moved moved
to Atlanta Georgia to Atlanta yeah so
now your team growing up there would be
well the Atlanta Braves I mean the
tomahawk choppin baseball poppin ain't
no stopping you know like during the 90s
I mean but you know it's like Dale
Murphy you know back in the day
you know yeah Fulton County Stadium and
and and all of that you go to Fulton
County you see some oh god yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was uh you know I mean
where I grew up
you know I grew up in a little town just
west of Atlanta it was kind of the last
area to really kind of be developed or
consumed by Atlanta so very still you
know a small town but you know you had
God and and barbecue and and football
and I mean you had you had baseball as
well but that was a you know it was a
big trip to go to the Fulton County
Stadium and watch the Braves I'm not
sure it's your guy yeah of corner yeah
third baseman believe me I had about a
million Bob Horner baseball cards oh wow
but Dale Murphy was a special player man
special player yeah I think he did this
commercial I just remember I don't know
I might be wrong but okay I remember
seeing Dale Murphy do this these these
commercials for canet ice cream look you
know yeah I mean TBS was a big deal
that's where the Braves played it was a
705 is when the game started and
Marshall Faulk grew up on in the New
Orleans area one of the Great's of all
time
and he grew up a Braves fan because the
superstation is right all the way across
the southeast and the Gulf South I mean
yeah so many Braves fans and places far
away yeah cities it didn't have teams
right always had that the Braves that I
think that's the reason why they're
Monica was the Americas team America's
Team I remember all that and then you
know obviously the Glavine Smoltz Maddux
there are the Bobby Cox I mean well the
moment like we're we're Sid Bream scored
on that Francisco Cabrera Cabrera right
yeah yeah and I was with you know all of
my friends I was living out here at the
time right but happened to kind of be
back there for that experience and
watched it in and Buckhead this little
bitty area oh sure Atlanta right before
it before it changed back for Zack when
Buckhead yeah post yeah yeah and and it
was extraordinary it was just you know
what what that moment like what sports
does for people man it brings everyone
together and obviously you know Atlanta
fans so starving you know the Falcons
coming so close in the Superbowl up 28
to 3 a couple of years ago and yeah you
know and Chris is uh you know what your
your girlfriend your your your partner
your life partner about to give birth to
a child she's a die-hard Atlanta and
Georgia sports fan so I've got it's
funny I've got a list of names of
Atlanta sports fans names that have
we've been joking he's gonna name his
child and you know interesting that some
of the names you have mentioned what
about what I mean I because also when I
when I lived in Atlanta this year after
I I didn't graduate college but like my
my summer break or whatever after my
freshman year college
I have Valley parked for uh for a club
owned by Dominique Wilkins
it was called you know Dominic's and and
then I think it went to Evander
Holyfield and I it was you know it was a
super cool club in Atlanta and and it
was just me I'm an the parking lot by
myself like I was making $600 $700 a
night come on in 1990 man like I mean it
was ace ordinary parking like like
literally 20 cars and and they just they
all like me
was cool and and and I just kind of hung
out with there you know although their
bins is I'm sorry Vander sorry but yeah
you got took a couple around but you
know that I had like you know some some
great stories and it was it was a place
to be seen man it was a real like a kind
of moment like in Atlanta's history and
it was just one time that this this guy
this is priests cellphones right even
car phones but they're the big car
phones yeah yeah and it was this guy man
and he was just going back and forth in
my lot and I was really protective of my
lot a protective of all these dudes cars
because they were paying me 50 bucks a
pop and it's Dominique Wilkins Dominique
Wilkins man it's a cool club and he had
this phone and he was going back and
forth with this loud music and and at
one point in the night he was he's still
doing it and and the bouncer in the club
ran out and said call 9-1-1 call 9-1-1 a
fight had broken out and there was no
phone around so I saw this guy and I
went running up to him I said dude I
gotta use your phone you got to call the
police you got to call the palo call the
police and he just looked at he said
it's fake its fake its fake phone he'd
been having fake conversations for an
hour on this phone I heard him having
conversations out loud on this phone so
stupid yeah it was great walton goggins
here on the Rich Eisen show before we
get into the Unicorn I got to ask you
about some other shows justified how did
you get into the role of Boyd Crowder
that was some really dark deep stuff
that you were bringing to the screen
thank you very much for saying welcome
you know I mean it's first and foremost
is based on a short story you know by
Elmore Leonard and who is one of our
great fiction writers and and so much so
that you know it's the only movie that
Quentin has made Jackie Brown other than
something that he's penned right and I
you know I don't know I just put him up
there with with the best and and so when
I when I read the pilot for the first
time I actually turned it down twice
because I
the things that he was saying you know
and III didn't want to see my culture
yet depicted again through such a narrow
narrow kind of point of view you know
and and so I said look in order for me
to do this and and FX they're really
good friends of mine and and Tim wasn't
a friend but you know kind of became a
friend but I said to Graham Yost or
creator and to Michael dinner our
director I said I just need two things I
need four for Tim to say that you know I
know that you don't believe this mmm you
know that you're saying it because you
want people to to worship you if you
will or whatever you you you get off on
having followers and there was something
else that I said and and they said okay
would you you'll do it if we do those
two things I said yep absolutely and and
it was the chemistry was just their own
amazing television man amazing
television and the writing was
incredible in the way you brought it to
life and you've Tim you referred to his
Tim Olaf an who played you know Raylan
Gibbons who was who was trying to put
you behind bars for so many years in
that show you know but I mean it really
kind of explored like you know I come
from this part of the world and and you
know all of my buddies you know have
buddies that join the service I mean I'm
the only guy I say I had 10 of my best
friends in my high school eight of them
joined the military that's that's what
you did you know if you wanted to kind
of get out I I chose to go to Los
Angeles manages to become like like an
actor I really just kind of see the
world and and you know they had an
incident happen at basic training and
and that forever cemented their bond
with the people that they went through
that with that experience would the same
thing with digging coal the same thing
with anything that you do and one's
youth whenever you experience trauma
together are difficult periods in your
life you were forever tied to that
person even if you have a different
political point of view or if you come
from a different kind of status and
economically in society whatever that is
you have that the commonality of that
experience and and that's what these two
men had and and and at the end of it I
think we all just wanted to
see where it would take us and like Tim
Olyphant you have been in a Quentin
Tarantino film you mentioned Quentin
before Tim was just didn't once upon a
time in Hollywood you're in Django
Unchained Olaf Aunt Hilda and the
hateful eight hateful eight to fart
pardon me on that front but but yeah
okay look when you're in now and when a
quittin Tarantino film you it should be
properly counted the old fan told an
incredible story about how no cell
phones were allowed on the set
you needed to just focus and what
Tarantino was like what was he like to
deal with you know I mean I don't think
like it's like not to deal with I'm
supposed to just be in the to be with to
be in his company right right and you
know there's no person that I have
worked with over the course of my 30
years in this business that has ever
been more infectious who's you know
their their energy has borne been more
infectious and their their love and
their deep understanding of storytelling
you know he lives it and he breathes it
and and it and it and it goes out to
those who are fortunate enough to get
the opportunity to work with him all
boats rise on his set and and it was an
extraordinary extraordinary experience
I'm grateful that I can call him my
friend and then you know man you just do
so many intense things the shield did
you realize at the time what that show
was like I know I know I mean I know
Michael Chiklis is gonna show a few
times and uh and and no none of none of
us didn't know nobody knew what FX was
you know I was a time in my life were
you know I'd been fortunate enough to do
movies for for a number of years but
anything really in television and
network television which was really kind
of the only game in town I don't have a
face for that like that's that's just
people didn't look at me back then
people barely look at me now and think
until now right
and think like yeah that guy's perfect
for Beverly Hills 90210 yeah we'll take
him but it but it took you know the FX
kind of coming up and and an HBO The
Sopranos right was the first but the
shield was number two
you know we were all in the air like six
months after the Sopranos and and it
took that kind of a gritty storytelling
I suppose for people like me to get a
shot and and when we were doing the
pilot here in LA you know I remember no
one knew kind of what was permissible
and not permissible like in regards to
language learn regards to you know
smoking and and and I and actually said
this once and I have a cigarette while
you wash this car or this car wash while
these drug dealers come on down and so
they all looked at each other said uh
sure yeah go ahead yeah why not I don't
know go for it and and and you know kind
of everything about that show and it was
only after that we did the pilot and and
this was you know but pre 9/11 and then
the pickup was post 9/11 right
conversations that took place in order
to kind of make that decision but when
when it first kind of came out and that
first episode came out like man we might
be sitting on something here and and but
Sean Ryan and the rest of us told that
first season as if we would never get
another season and if you watch it it
has a beginning a middle and an end
mm-hmm and one where we could all kind
of walk away from and little did we know
that we were going to be some of the
first actors alive really to be going
through you know an 84 our next
exploration of what it what it means to
be these people that were betraying
those extraordinary man really and I
think it I think anyone on The Sopranos
would say the exact same thing I mean
out of the gate and I know Bryan
Cranston would say the same thing about
Breaking Bad yeah I mean anybody that's
getting gotten the opportunity to tell a
story a serialized story right over over
85 hours you know you leave no stone
unturned and we certainly didn't do that
on the shield Walton Goggins here on the
Rich Eisen show now you're the Unicorn
bro I mean I mean network television
network about that television just stay
around long enough and yeah down now
you're that single father trying to find
a new life with your apt your wife
passed and now you're the unicorn
because you're walking around town and
and you're catch this is dear to the
catch
yeah of Los Angeles how about how about
that I think it could
get past all of what's going on between
your temples now yeah that's right yeah
yeah you know IIIi again I I never
really saw myself in network television
I stopped thinking about that a very
long time ago and but you know like it
like a lot of actors I really kind of
follow the words on the page and what's
the best kind of thing out there and and
when this came across my desk I read it
and thought wow you know if they were to
do this you know a different way I don't
know if they would really kind of be up
for that but they were to let me do my
thing regardless of whether or not it
got picked up I think it could actually
do some good in the world and something
that that I would like to be part of and
and so you know I met with them was the
invitation to meet well then one of the
producers had got him Peyton Reed who
was a good friend of mine and directed
ant-man on the wasp and and his two
friends our writers Bill Martin and Mike
Schiff and they wrote this story based
on their best friend who from college
and and he lost his wife to cancer very
young and he had two teenage daughters
and and a year into his grieving process
he looked at his friends that were
writers and said do you think this would
make a good television show they said
but we've been waiting for a year right
I didn't say yeah but you did spell and
say
they said yes make a great show yeah and
and so here we are man we did it and
it's funny too it's got a sweet Center I
mean we've had Omar Miller and Rob
Corddry on to talk about it too
no you have yes we're quite familiar
with your show sir yeah on the same with
your work how in the what else a this
you know like I don't know for me I I'm
an earnest guy I'm not a quick eye right
she's not my thing
I suppose my humor comes from
storytelling our situational humor right
no I'm not a I'm not a commit and I
don't want to be a comedian I want to be
me right and but but this story for me
as funny as it is we knew it would be
funny and I told CBS I said I promise
you will it'll be funny
mm-hmm but we gotta land it I don't
think you can talk about this kind of
thing without really going there and
emotionally yeah and and all the people
at CBS were so unbelievably supportive
right out of the gate regardless again
whether or not we got picked up right
but the thing that I will say that I
want to say on your show because I
haven't really said this anywhere else
is that look man we all we all grieve
you know we all go through difficult
periods in our life and I think most of
us like even empty-nesters you know like
like a child going off to college or the
loss of a pet
whatever that is let alone the loss of a
spouse or the loss of a child or the
loss of a job I think it's in those
moments that we feel most isolated we
feel most alone and that that there is
no one there to grieve us and and my
intention there only reason that I did
this show because I've been there is to
say that you know what we're not alone
and that you're not the first person to
go through it and he won't be the last
and and if we can put something out into
the world where most content most comedy
is is cynical which is funny is I can
say it's funny I can say that
hey well it's like it's funny but but
okay well then okay Todd you were drunk
oh okay so but no what I totally know
what you're saying though Walt and I I
just recently lost my dad and the thing
that really blew me away was the number
of people who said you know what I've
lost a parent too and I'm here for you
yeah man I'm here for you reached out
yeah people hadn't heard from a while
yeah and I thought you know what I was
alone and I I actually joined this club
that I had no idea that existed and and
it is just you know getting together and
talking it out yeah man so helpful and
if we if we that's what if we could
create this show and tell this story
right it might ease that burden or make
people look at their situation and how
absurd it is and it can be that it might
lighten their load you know and and here
I'm here to tell you man a you know a
year into there are eight months into
this now I've been stopped on the street
and and I've become a repository for
other people's grieving good for you and
and I and I love it and good for you I
do I love it yeah and I've been there
with my mother and I'll just say this I
haven't lost a parent yet but but my mom
went through some tough times and and I
had to move her to Los Angeles yeah you
know I'm alone you know I'm an only
child I mean I have a half-brother with
my dad it's a long story
he's 14 years younger than me but with
my mom I'm alone and um and I I didn't
know where to go rich I have no idea I
don't know how do I take care of my mom
she's up we always had our little house
and our agreement was you take care of
your side of the street I'll take care
of mine and and and I had to look for a
place out here and I was just
overwhelmed and consumed with all of
these decisions and responsibilities and
I'll make this quick I promise and I
went into this end of this facility
where she is here is just a retirement
community and and I walked out and I was
just bawling how can i how can I do this
I don't know what to do and I looked up
I saw a guy walking down the street who
was bawling with two bags of groceries
and I said Dan he said Walton I said
what are you doing here he said I just
moved my mom in here last night and I
said oh my god and he just walked me
through his process and it's like I'm
not
he's going through all my other friends
are going through if we just only have
the courage to actually community that's
fun really sometimes you just don't have
the courage to do it do you think you'd
get stepping out of your skin but again
that sort of show like the Unicorn is
all about Thursdays at 8:30 p.m. Eastern
including tonight that's right on CBS
can you stick around for one television
segment just one more minute segment cuz
I wanted to ask you about Danny McBride
before you go I just got it I want to
talk about okay I got about a two-minute
segment that's next with the walton
goggins right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 under red TV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app